تنطلق ظهور اليوم في مدينه جده السعوديه
اعمال القمه العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين من
المقرر ان تبحث القمه عده قضايا رئيسيه من
بينها القضيه الفلسطينيه والازمه
السودانيه بالاضافه الى ملفات اقتصاديه في
اطار الخطط التنمويه للجامعه العربيه وقد
وصل يوم امس عدد من رؤساء الدول العربيه
من بينهم الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
والرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد والرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي والرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس
كما وصل ايضا رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي وملك البحرين
محمد ولد الشيخ احمد الغزواني اضافه الى
نائب رئيس الوزراء اسعد بن طارق رئيسي
وفدي سلطنه عمان
من المركز الاعلامي للقمه العربيه في جده
مراسله الجزيره جامع نور معه ندخل في
اجواء هذه القمه قبل انطلاقها عن الملفات
التي سيتم تداولها من قبل من يحضر هذه
القمه في جده جامع
تسمعني الان
الاستضافه اي نعم اسمعك اسمعني
نعم عبد القادر جده تضع اللمسات الاخيره
لانطلاقه القمه الثاني والثلاثون للجامعه
الدول العربيه والتي من المتوقع ان تبدا
بعد الثانيه بتوقيت مسبه معدن الثانيه
مساء بتوقيت جده عدد من القيادات العربيه
وصلت الى الى جده حوالي 15 الى 17 قائدا
عربيا وصل الى الى جده والباقي في طريقهم
الى هنا ومن المتوقعا يصل قبل بدايه هذه
القمه هناك ملفات كثيره
ستتطرق الى في داخل في هذه القمه ومن
اهمها القضيه الفلسطينيه الشان السوداني
الملف اللبنان ملف اليمن وملفات اقتصاديه
وامنيه
وتجاريه كثيره حقيقه هي قمه فيها جدول
الاعمال فيها زاخر بقضايا كثيره والكل
يتطلع الى وستخرج من هذه القمه عبد القادر
الجديد في هذه القمه هو حضور رئيس بشار
الاسد الذي يحضر هذه القمه بعد 12 عاما
من تجميد عضويه سوريا لكل هذه القضايا
المطروحه في جدول اعمال جده قمه جده معي
عيسى العميري ليطلعنا لنساله عن كيف
تستطيع القاده مع كل هذه الملفات الشائكه
بدءا من القضيه الفلسطينيه التي تشهد
تطورات خطيره بالملف السوداني ملف اليمني
كل هذه الملفات ان يتطرقوا اليها ويخرج
بصيغه تغير من هذه من هذا الواقع طبعا في
البدايه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الشرف ان
يكون ضيف عبر قناه الجزيره والشكر على
استضافه وانا اتحدث الان وصول مع امير
دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن ثاني حفظ الله
ورعاه اليوم ننطلق من الايه الكريمه تقول
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وتعاونوا على البر
والتقوى سوره المائده صدق الله العظيم
اليوم يعني
تطورات ايجابيه سريعه اليوم ننطلق من
سؤالك اليوم يعني
ادانا خليجيه عربيه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي داخل مجلس الاقصى وان
دل يحاول يعني افشاء القمه العربيه او
بوصل صوره مش حلوه لنجاح القمه العربيه
طبعا اليوم من ضمن البنود الاساسيه كما
اسلفت القضيه الفلسطينيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه هي الاساس هي المكمل هي القضيه
الاساسيه العربيه الازليه لم ولن نتنازل
عنها مهما كلفنا من امر النقطه الثانيه
المصالحه
الداخليه الفلسطينيه من ضمن البنود
المتوقعه الاتفاق عليها باذن الله اليوم
اليوم نرى كذلك الاتفاق يعني الذي وقع في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في مارس الماضي
بين كل من الجمهوريه العربيه الاسلاميه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه بواساطه صينيه
وحلت كثير من الملفات في المنطقه ورايناها
على ارض الواقع منها طبعا ارجاع الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه الى الحضن العربي بعد
انقطاع اكثر من 12 سنه الى الحضن العربي
وبالتالي عندنا كذلك الملفات العالقه
قضايا كثيره منها طبعا تم توقيع مؤخرا على
الاتفاقيات اللي نزعت الازمه بين يعني
الجيش السوداني والفصائل الاخرى وقعت طبعا
الازمه وصفت في السودان من 20 من رمضان
واثرت على كثير من الدول العربيه
والافريقيه وبالتالي وقع مؤخرا لنزعه
الازمه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه والان
باذن الله في طريقه
الكل يعرف ان هذه المشاكل كلها موجوده
ومطرقه وتداعياتها ظاهره في الواقع في
الواقع عربي لكن ما ينظر اليه
المواطن العربي هو ما الذي سيميز هذه
القمه عن سابقاتها هل سيكون القرارات التي
ستصدر من هذه القمه هي ما تعود عليه
الشارع العربي ام سيكون هناك شيء مختلف عن
القمم السابقه اليوم القمه انا احس وجهه
نظري كوني كاتب محلل وسياسي وتطور للشان
الخليجي والعربي ان اليوم القمه ليس
كسابقاتها اليوم القمه العربيه 32 في جده
قمه غير مسبوقه قمه استثنائيه ليس كسائق
لغتها لقمه الجزائر وليس كقمه قادمه بكثير
من الدلائل اليوم راينا على ارض الواقع في
دلائل اليوم حفاظ على الهويه العربيه
اليوم ارجاع سوريا وشريك اساسي وعربي في
المنطقه اليوم
المسار الليبي الليبي في الطريق السليم
اليوم المسار السوداني الخطوات الاخيره
اليوم الازمه اليمنيه في الطريق الاتجاه
الصحيح اليوم الشارع العربي سال مرارا
وتكرارا ولكن اليوم متفائل يبعد حدود لان
اول مره يحضرون 22 قاده من دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي والعربي وهذا مؤشر جيد
فبالتالي نعم في قضيه الاساسيه قضيه
الارهاب التي عصفت في الدول الخليجيه
والعربيه بحار ضمن القمه تنبيع يعني وقت
منابع الارهاب والقضاء عليه وبالتالي عانت
كثير من الدول
دكتور صحيح لكن هناك مثلا اتتحدثت عن عوده
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الصحيح انه عاد
بعد 12 عاما من تجميد عضويه سوريا لكن
ايضا تثير تساؤلات ماذا عن الاف الضحايا
ماذا عن المهجرين ماذا عن كل هؤلاء اليوم
يعني
ارجاع الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه الى
الحضن العربي وهذا يعني سويت انا يعني
خلال المقابلات امس في القنوات السوريه
يعني حابين نحضن نلم الشملي العربي اليوم
سوريا رجعت ولكن في توجد قضيه النازحين
وتوجد اعاده تمويل لسوريا فبالتالي قضيه
النازحين اليوم يجب ارجاعهم من دول لبنان
بجمهوريه العربيه اللبنانيه من تركيا الى
دولهم وبالتالي مساعدين في عام عاده اعمار
سوريا اليوم مشكله بسيطه يمكن تواجه سوريا
قانون قيصر الاقتصادي التي اثر على
اقتصادياتها فبالتالي في ضمن الخطه
المتعارف عليها يكون تمويل سوريا وتمويل
لنخرج الى الاطار العالمي هناك استقطاب
دوله بسبب الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا على
امريكا هي تريد ان تستقطب العالم العربي
كله في صفها هناك روسيا هي ايضا تريد ان
تستقبل العلنه اين سيكون موقع العرب تجاه
هذه التوقعات والتموقعات في في المشهد
السياسي العالمي انا يعني انا ذكرتها
واذكرها الان ان يعني الدول والدول
العربيه هي قادره على راب الصدع بين بعضهم
هي قادره على اللحمه والوحده الوطنيه
قادره على التكامل الاقتصادي اليوم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ذكرتها
والاتحاد الاوروبي الى اللحظه هذا في توجد
مسائلهم بعدم حضور بشار الاسد او بافشال
القمه السوريه او اليوم راينا الاستيطان
الاسرائيلي بوصل رساله للقمه العربيه اني
انا قادر اني ادخل الى المسجد الاقصى هذه
رساله سلبيه ولكن في ارض الواقع اليوم
القمه هذه ليس كساب
حقيقه
الانظار تبقى تنتظر ما سيخرج من القمه
العربيه التي من المتوقع ان تختتم مساء
هذا اليوم اليك عبد القادر شكرا لك يا
جماعه نور كنت معنا وايضا لضيفك الكريم
كنت معنا من المركز الاعلامي للقمه
العربيه في جده